تعلن روسيا اعتراضها على استمرار
الاتفاقيه التي تسمح اسعار القمح في سوق
شيكاغو ارتفعت بنسبه 3% تقول موسكو ان
البنود المتعلقه بتصدير حبوبها واسمنتها
لا تحتر انه
بعد انسحاب روسيا من اتفاقيه الحبوب
اوروبا تطرح طرقا بديله للاستيراد من
اوكرانيا لكن هذه الطرق تصطدم بعقبات
كثيره الان جميع السفن المتوجهه الى مياه
البحر الاسود والموانئ الاوكرانيه ستعتبر
من قبلنا ناقلات لشحنات عسكريه
ما هي مسارات التضامن الاوروبيه
موانئ دول البلطيق تصفها المفوضيه
الاوروبيه بانها خط مهم للغايه ووسيله
بديله وموثوقه لشحن الحبوب الاوكرانيه
تسمح بارسال 25 مليون طن من الحبوب سنويا
تنطلق الشحنات برا من اوكرانيا نحو بولندا
ثم تتابع بحرا نحو موانئ دول البلطيق
الثلاث لتوانيا واستونيا ولاتفيا لكن هذا
المسار يواجه عراقيل تبدا من الاختناقات
الحدوديه بين اوكرانيا وبولندا اضافه
لطاقه الموانئ الاستيعابيه وقدرتها
المحدوده على التصدير
بات بديلا مهما بعد الحصار البحري الذي
فرضته روسيا في 2022
وتمتلك اوكرانيا من اين على النهر هما
ريمي واسمائيل التجار المحليون استخدموا
النهر لايصال الشحنات نحو الحدود مع
رومانيا وبلغ حجم المحاصيل المنقوله عبر
النهر مليونين ومئتي الف طن في مايو ايار
الماضي بزياده تقارب 900 الف طن عن نهايه
العام 2022 لكن النهر كان عرضه لهجمات
صاروخيه في الاسابيع الماضيه ويحد فصل
الصيف من حركه السفن فيه لانخفاض منسوب
المياه وتبلغ كلفه النقل النهري اضعاف
الشحن بالبحر
[موسيقى]
السكك الحديديه هذا الخيار طرح لمعالجه
وصول الشحنات الى نهر الدانوب او لنقل
الشحنات مباشره عبر القطارات نحو اوروبا
لكن نظام السكك في اوكرانيا يختلف عن
امثاله في اوروبا لا سيما مقياس السكك
وتحملها للقطارات ويستغرق بناء نظام
قطارات جديد وقتا طويلا وتكاليف باهظه
الطرق البريه
يكون عبر ارسال الحبوب بشاحنات من
اوكرانيا نحو ثلاثه منافذ بريه ومنه تتابع
الشحنات برا الى انحاء اوروبا لكن الدول
التي تمتلك منافذ مباشره مع اوكرانيا من
الجهه الغربيه ورغم انها تدعم كييف وتوفر
لها السلاح والمال فان مصالحها التجاريه
تتعارض مع تمرير شحنات الحبوب الاوكرانيه
لان ذلك يضر بانتاجها وصادراتها المحليه
ولا سيما بولندا
خلاصه القول ان صادرات الاغذيه والاسمده
من اوكرانيا وروسيا لا تزال تكتسي اهميه
قصوى لضمان الامن الغذائي العالمي
[موسيقى]